- Hey y'all,
welcome to Is This Okay,
where we talk about things that people
aren't talking about.
I'm Nyla.
- Ooh, I'm Becky.
- I'm Daysha.
- I'm Chris.
- And I'm Morgan.
(group laughs)
- So, today,
we'll be discussing
Colin Kaepernick's recent
protest for every NFL game,
due to racial injustice,
everything that's happening in the world,
where blacks are being killed by police,
and it's gaining nationwide attention.
Other people have been doing it.
Other NFL stars, I think there
are a few soccer players,
and now, it's kind of branching
out towards high schools
and, you know, so it's
getting a lot of attention.
- We live in a country where
there's freedom of expression.
And I don't even think that
this is a debate to be had.
Like, if you don't believe in
what your government's doing,
protest.
Why are people up in arms about it?
I mean, do we know why
people are so up in arms?
- A lot of it comes out
of disrespect for...
- Veterans.
- America.
- Yeah, the military.
- 9/11, and stuff like that.
But at the same time, when you think about
the conversation on protest,
it's like whoa, you know,
they always riot.
And they steal, and they
loot, and they do whatever,
so, it's like now,
I think what's frustrating about this
is that you have an example of someone
who's peacefully protesting.
Like, all he's doing,
is kneeling or sitting,
and yet, people want to burn his jersey.
They want to send him death threats.
- I don't think he deserves death threats
and I don't think he
deserves to be attacked,
but I also do think that
the people, not all people,
but some people who are
upset by his actions
can't be completely disregarded,
because I found myself very torn,
because I realized in that moment,
I was like, part of me wants to be like,
"I'm always preaching
about you should be able to
"protest peacefully, as
long as it's peaceful,"
blah, blah, blah.
But then, we did this,
it also is a huge symbol, and so,
I can't completely disregard
people who find it offensive.
So, I was more, like, in the middle.
- Yeah, I do feel like it is a matter
of people disagreeing with him.
I don't think they bother looking at
the nuance and the
actual reasons behind why
he is doing what he's doing.
- I was in New York City,
in lower Manhattan on 9/11.
There were people a lot closer than me,
but I was pretty damn in it for 9/11,
and it was a fucking horrible day.
And, I absolutely am
grateful to the military.
I have family members
that are in the military.
They fight for our country.
That's amazing.
They're selfless.
I think that...
Being proud of our country
and feeling the patriotism,
unity as a country,
is not mutually exclusive,
from saying there's something wrong here,
and we need to do something about it,
and someone like Colin
Kaepernick is in a position
to take a knee and start
a national conversation.
- He took a stand and didn't tell anybody,
because he didn't wanna be stopped,
and I think that's important,
especially as a black American.
When we fight for our rights,
we should never have to ask permission,
to corporate organizations,
who are majority white men, saying like,
hey, is this okay?
I am fighting for my
right, as a black American,
because something is wrong,
and I have that right,
as an American, to do so.
- But, I think it's also important to note
that when he decided instead of sitting,
he was gonna take a knee,
it was because he went
and had a conversation
with a military elder.
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- He said that he agreed.
There's a problem in this
country we need to fix,
but, here's something that
we can do that's in between.
- When you think about it, all it was
was this guy, who was
against something that's
obviously a problem,
and all he was doing,
was just not standing,
or putting his hand over his heart,
for the national anthem.
But, the fact that it went
from like, "He's an asshole,"
to, "I want him to die."
- [Morgan] Right.
- And people being like, "Good for him,"
to like, "He is a god,"
I think, shows how much the
country's upset right now.
- [Morgan] Oh yeah.
- Because everyone just
use that as this symbolic thing.
- Yeah!
- He lit a fuse.
- It's like this flagpole of patriotism.
- It was huge!
- Yeah.
- I mean, he even said he was like,
"It's interesting to see
"how racism, how patriotism
"is being, kind of like the
cover for racism right now."
- Oh my god!
- [Becky] Yeah!
- [Morgan] Oh my god!
- And that was real!
And that's true!
- Yeah, totally!
- And like, a valid point is that,
and this brings up a
whole other conversation,
but the national anthem is racist.
But, I mean, you can easily look it up.
- Yeah.
- You can be like,
national anthem, is it racist, or naw?
And it will be like, yeah, it is!
- Do we sing the...?
- No, we don't
sing that part anymore.
- We don't sing that part,
and that's why a lot of people
don't know that it's racist,
is because we don't sing that.
- With all that said though,
because the country's
never gonna be perfect,
then our dues can never really allowed
to be patriotic?
Like, I actually don't know the answer.
I'm actually asking just
what do you guys think?
- [Daysha] I don't know.
I think I always think back
to early American history.
And you think about how this
country was built on the fact
that people threw tea into the water,
and they said F this!
Like, I'm not gonna do this!
And so, when I think about that,
and how that's how our country started,
and then I think about
Kaepernick taking a knee,
it's like, are you serious?
- Yeah.
- Totally!
- I almost now feel like
it feels weird, then, to ever
stand for the national anthem,
unless the country is perfect,
'cause I feel like every time,
if you ever do stand for it,
are you ignoring the cause?
- Right, are you, yeah.
- 'Cause if it's not
police brutality, it's rape.
It's, I don't know, it's
just tons of things.
It's economic.
It's justice.
It's just all this other stuff,
and so, at what point,
should we never be doing that?
Is that always disgraceful?
- I mean, I think that as a society,
we have an internal national gauge,
that seems to go
how systemic is this problem?
- I think another big problem too, though,
is that we don't like to revisit things.
We don't really like to change things.
So, it's like, you wanna say,
why don't you follow the law,
and if you just follow the
law, you wouldn't get shot.
- Who is the law written by?
- But, this law wasn't written
with me in mind.
This law didn't see me as
a person to begin with.
- Yeah.
- It never really had me
in its center.
So, that's kind of the problem,
and I agree that we
need some kind of order.
That's kind of how society works.
But at the same time, why
can't we revisit these things?
- Yeah.
- Why can't we have
conversations?
- Alright, so I think that is
the end of today's episode.
Let us know what you guys
think in the comments below.
And we'll see you guys next week.
(relaxing electronic music)